it's safe to say that Apple's got the
tablet Market locked up but there are a
number of people out there that aren't
into the Apple ecosystem they prefer
Android so you got Samsung you got
Huawei but you might not have thought of
xiaomi for a tablet you should I've been
playing with a pad 5 for the past couple
weeks and this tablet shocked me at how
good it is especially for the price
point here it is my review of the xiaomi
pad 5.
now like all our reviews we're not paid
or sponsored unless we tell you I was a
little unsure if I wanted to actually do
a review on this now you know xiaomi
Singapore who are very kind enough to
send this over said Bobby just give it a
shot try it out as soon as I open this
thing up and I powered it on and I
started loading up the apps and playing
around with it I was
very impressed I'm like okay guys I
gotta talk to you about this because I
know a lot of you out there say hey look
what else is there to use besides the
iPad another Android tablet what are
some options and I'm gonna say this is
one as I mentioned earlier you need to
take a look at now here's what we're
going to do for the review we're going
to show you what it's like to edit on
Lightroom we're going to do some web
browsing we'll do some video play as
well and then we'll do some gameplay and
I got Xeno here who's our gamer who's
going to be coming over here playing
some genshin show you what it's like to
use now we'll be doing screen recording
on this so there may be a little bit of
lack of performance due to that because
obviously it's a little bit taxi on the
system but you'll get an idea of who
this tablet's for in terms of that now
if you're a hardcore gamer I don't think
this might be the tablet for you but if
you're Casual Gamer you're like look I
use my tablets to you know watch YouTube
videos Netflix whatever Disney plus and
I want to do a little bit of casual
gaming I think you may be impressed so
with that let's get down to trying out
this tablet okay first off specs the 11
inch tablet runs a Snapdragon 860
processor in the this version has a six
gigabyte 120 gigabytes of storage sizes
about 8 700 something milliamp batteries
so this is a very large battery and a
tablet it's pretty much part and parcel
with what you're getting with a lot of
11 inch tablets on this 120 hertz
display on this and you're going to get
that Dolby Atmos Vision sound and that
Clarity you're gonna get that P3 color
gamut one billion colors this thing is
stacked and I also have the pencil with
it as well or the pen which magnetizes
to the top of it you might have seen
that on other tablets out there in apple
terms of cameras on there on the back of
you got a 13 megapixel camera then of
course you can do 4K video on the front
you got 1080p video for your
front-facing camera as well so if you
want to do web conferencing it looks
really good
it's it's it's fantastic man I really
like this thing anyway let's get on to
some testing right here okay let's do it
okay first off we are going to go in to
Lightroom real quick here now I've got a
lot of photos on this uh so it might
take a little bit but I'll just pull
into some some photos here to get an
idea what we're looking at
the pen is very responsive on this and
you also get an extra tip when you do
get the pen inside of it too so just in
case you need that but I'm not seeing
much delay on this it's pretty accurate
then of course I can just uh enhance the
clarity a little bit if I want add the
textures
all looks really good
now in terms of the tablet usage
obviously when you're using Android
versus Apple right the apps are
developed a little bit differently so
this is not a comparison between an iPad
and also the xiaomi pad 5. but if you're
into the Android space you already kind
of know what it's like to use but I mean
looking at my images right here I shot
on a 45 megapixel camera it's sharp the
colors look great no issues at all now I
am doing a screen record on top of this
so there might be a little bit of lag
because of that screen recording but
again performs beautifully let's go to
Netflix real quick here
Cleopatra's first egg is on display I
mean it's beautiful sharp you can hear
the audio coming from these speakers
great movie experience
I'm gonna pause that right now obviously
for copyright reasons I can't play you a
larger clip but you're gonna get the
idea that again this is a really good
video experience on this tablet also you
got the multitasking right here very
easy to use
bring it back now again with the way the
tablet's designed actually I feel more
comfortable using an important mode than
I do in landscape mode it is a quite
like a 16 by 10 ratio on this so I mean
for movie play obviously landscape but
if you're just going to be daily tasks
like this browsing the web I would hold
it in portrait mode for the most part I
mean it feels more comfortable that way
let's go into some browsing real quick
here all the latest news going on here
allow some uh
notifications from Geek culture a lot of
ads we had a lot of ads on our website
here so don't mind those
got to make money somehow you know what
I mean I got same-day appointments man
got to pay the bills as we say you got
to pay the bills you know so if you're
looking for a dentist we've got you
covered on that one
yeah I mean again very easy to use when
you're browsing at this size it's very
nice to read documents check out things
like that no issues at all so and the
one thing again I like is the vibrancy
and the brightness of this this display
now is it the brightest display on a new
tablet not necessarily but it's great
for indoor usage it's great for outdoor
usage it does adapt now again you can
adjust based on the color temperature
depending on the lighting Source you
could do that as well kind of like the
true tone that Apple has you can get
that same sort of similar uh experience
with this tablet I turn it off for the
most part because I do a lot of photo
editing and I don't want something to go
more warm than it is depending if I'm
shooting you know editing at night time
or whatever the case is or in Lower
Lights so you know to each their own on
that but I gotta say this is a very
pleasant experience holding this tablet
it's very lightweight guys this is paper
thin it is such a pleasant tablet to
hold I would say it feels a little bit
lighter than the iPad for the most part
to be honest with you I mean if you want
to compare it to that so let's show a
little bit of writing example real quick
here
that's my name
very smooth this is very very smooth so
on the pen you can actually control it
to do let's say screen capture you do
the whole screen you can do a window
whatever it is you want to do
and you can share it you can start over
give you that so if you're do you know
taking symptom notes you're looking at a
website looking at a document you just
want to cut a piece of that out and
share it to somebody you can do that as
well all right so now we're going to do
is I'm going to have Xeno come over here
since he's the gaming guy and he's gonna
actually play some gunshon for us and
show you what it's like to play now
again we are doing some screen recording
on this so there may not be the Optimal
Performance out of this but as you know
walk you through that so we'll get to
that and I'll give you my final thoughts
right after this let's talk about
today's sponsor Logitech here at geek
culture audio is a huge part of our
daily lives both work and play so what's
our choice of headphones well meet the
Logitech g435 light speed wireless
gaming headset it lets you listen to all
the rich sounds from your music videos
and games across PC console and mobile
while sporting some popping vibrant
colors not only that it weighs just 165
grams which means sometimes you'll even
forget that you're wearing it with the
robust battery life of 18 hours you can
enjoy your gaming sessions for prolonged
periods of time for more details head
over to logitechg.com
this is going to set things real quick
again everything's on the highest we had
60 FPS so this is the best we can do
though
it's got that 60 FPS yeah but other than
that it looks pretty all right and you
get the game boost on this as well oh
yeah right I forgot about that yeah so
it's clearing up it's freeing up uh
space on the tablet for me to play the
game
let's start the challenge real quick
okay
so far so good
okay okay well okay we got some frame
drops but I think that's because of the
screen recording the screen recording is
limiting quite a bit a lot but other
than that it looks pretty damn good okay
it feels great to play yeah oh okay so
the screen recording is off right now
but
let's get the audio out real quick
it does improve a smidgen okay just a
little bit but honestly with like six
six of RAM and everything as compared to
like say like the xiaomi blackshock 4
that we tried out this is the gaming
phone which is a gaming phone yeah this
I mean this thing's meant for like
casual use and everything but you can
definitely get some gaming on this thing
on the lower settings right yeah because
we are overclocking this thing right now
and we are pushing it to its limits
right so you know you obviously you want
to expect the best performance out of it
right but I don't know it's fine okay
final thoughts on the tablet as I
mentioned before I think it's fantastic
for the average user out there if you're
again not in the Apple ecosystem this is
something to take a look at there's a
lot of competition in the Android
Marketplace when it comes to tablets I
wasn't expecting the xiaomi pad 5 to be
this good but it actually is and I'm not
hater sponsored to say that I was very
impressed with it now a couple things
that I think could use Improvement now
again on the back of it it is a little
slick to hold like this now I don't have
the case obviously when you get the
cases that's going to alleviate that but
I wish it had a bit more of a matte
texture I think Xeno also mentioned this
as well and at the same time I feel like
on the display it's really nice got
great colors everything else but you
know on the xiaomi phones they give you
a lot of customization when it comes to
the display you can just you can choose
srgb P3 you can really fine tune it from
there I feel some of that customization
isn't in this tablet thus far now again
there is going to be a MIUI update
coming very soon I think within a month
or so that may be included and this
whole thought on the display may be null
and void but as it stands right now at
the end of November I would say that one
might be one of my only complaints about
it besides that six gigabytes of RAM as
we mentioned not gonna be optimal for a
Hardcore gameplay but it will do the job
this is not meant to be a pro tablet to
equal or match your laptop out there but
this is a nice accessory to take on with
you if you're in the bedroom home if you
want to give it to your kids family
members you know just watch some videos
as you're cooking or whatever the case
may be I think you're gonna really enjoy
this those are my thoughts on the xiaomi
battery five let me know your thoughts
in the comments section below is this a
tablet you're looking to pick up any
questions you have I will try to answer
those with you like always subscribe to
the channel follow us on Facebook like
this video as well stay safe and I'll
chat to you soon take care
[Music]